you're the number one Matt and live
player in the world that can't be real
that means can play all day that means
one day mommy doesn't kind of chronic
babble come around actually Michael is
like a vegetable and I see with clarity
husband like my name is Gary Thomas I've
been telling you how accountants of
equity I'll triple they given a pedigree
to convene and a pleasure my faculty
putting the work that I'm doing are the
movers come in what's going on is it
harder no no no I'm good how you doing
no reason to write I mean you know what
when you when you're young right yes
you're wrong different I like what you
get closer for you so once or nine
natural causes in shape you know
reduction just comes like you guys know
who Howard Bingham is famous
photographers so Howard Bingham son
Dustin I'm at the college was before my
best friend's coming Bob and his brother
stamen to the bialy movie with Will
Smith passed away I'm crazy Holly died a
man died and Howard Bingham died that
you might as well all within like a year
yeah yeah mmm
I can't wait on you a lot not a person
for life 400 trillion to one
you know that's my I thought about
everything like what not when I think
about the fact that my dad could have
you know if I take a [ __ ] and like like
you know how hard it is to become a
human like like 400 trillion for one
like there's no math like you can win
like 90 NBA championships in a row more
likely than being a human being so
that's its perspective once you get
there so what's going on - like I'm
super pumped we're here I'm sure my
fairness your work like what uh what's
get give me some contact yet laptop yep
I'm aware yep yep yep Anna I saw game
last week show here yep yeah myself I
didn't walk through there I asked you
know you know something
I generally don't Amane ly think you can
do a walk through the trees people
running after fella doctor quarter yeah
yeah Senate got yep and how long have
you guys been
[Music]
can you watch helping playing hockey is
a going drivers number look inspired by
my office today it means automatically
all number one they're real good you're
the number one Matt and live player in
the world
that can't be real some come in from
play all day my man there's no other way
like just like without [ __ ] like
they have like I haven't played Matt and
Wallach when we go on to like Xbox
whatever like Connie is like they have
the rankings right I'm number one on
every Xbox don't you do [ __ ] that's
unbelievable
why don't you a [ __ ] you go crazy in
which I mean think about that I got my
name right I [ __ ] grew up playing
video games and my grandmother's from
Texas and she's old southern and she
would just be like this [ __ ] kid the
game for anything game this game then
and so let's I got my name so before the
whole last name was just game my
nickname was game as a child growing up
I didn't know that when it became what I
was it's funny because when I when I
find the dr. Dre like I wasn't my place
that wasn't my rap and what was it it
was like [ __ ] ah [ __ ] is he confident
MC Compton he Compton and I had a Mike
Rockwell who everybody laughs it when he
asked me and I saw him comes out Rock
the mic well they're my mother's like my
younger sister who was now 27 she was
back then she's [ __ ] just like want
you to be your regular name
I'm like what she's like game just add
like a mister or like a doctor or is
like a duck and I love that story and
then so when I you know when I actually
wants us to do to meet Trey and a 250mm
that seems like what's your name I was
trying I'll stick it down I want to say
if she copies what I like okay welcome
back
that's good [ __ ] that's crazy okay now
Marcus Nintendo so wait a minute let's
take a step back like just on another
kick how do you think about eSports are
you thinking about that at all have you
opened up their eyes from that world I'm
just now like good getting off no my
console is starting to branch out and I
just got the PC gaming and eSports my
boy who's like a lot like number seven
in man putting me on him so what might
starting to you know get off that ball
came seriously on a very short circuit
like I know I know we've been through
this you're literally the number one
player on that and one this one that's
what the bet the car won the one that's
out right now like whatever 17 and what
would you end up being on 16 it is
correct
you're just unstoppable mad at me what
about live I don't play my own forgot
kick and and I'm this year I haven't
played in like head-to-head yep I've
been playing like my later that's the
biggest thing going TJ yeah I was number
one 2011 to take you
yeah and is it just sports cooking thing
you're that domitor or shooter games I
don't know I was the first modern world
for house number one I'll see you are
you have you ever been number two on
anything
yeah these course is going to be so
eSports is gonna be the number three
sport in American ten years before 1940
were you a twitch channel I wish I own
everything I get locked out of me
somehow why shouldn't she dream them
like a hundred thousand but it was the
beginning stage
yeah everybody wants to watch him farm
yep what uh I wanted the question
whatever what happened who do you play
with Oh Minnie
can you sir play with the just a little
bit more I need some more winded thank
you yes my man I was waiting to see the
doctor awhile he knows he plays let me
get for ya I play with their Niners and
I want to read games like I need to pull
okay so Carly I'm playing chief you know
dumb [ __ ] like polio defensive lineman
off the line like to like I think that's
how I got bad at Madden ice we couldn't
Madden 93 94 95
I'm just amongst my friends I got so
bored being good at it I started getting
the bad habit and then one should change
and I got busy I still I couldn't like
recovered haha dick change it for
everyone
what it says it outright that I've
always liked mention [ __ ] well my
quarter bag when they say when they got
dragged to the [ __ ] problem man
change reference and then one year they
can occupy coal power nothing relevant
yeah Warren Moon wasn't one of mine
about it [ __ ] man will come again
honey came with that you ever owned the
games like yeah yeah I'm gonna get
another big table with 96 peach like and
I wanted to do that involved like it was
just talking crazy normal yet I'm still
number one after that that's cool makes
sense I'm glad you did that
yeah yeah I mean like listen for my
standpoint open for business
like you know you something you got a
good understanding for me I prefer
leverage I'm so insular I'm going to get
mine regardless of what anybody does so
my basic thesis is like how do I give
how do I give and give without
expectation just give give give give
that's where all the leverage comes from
so you know if you want to get some more
established LPS for the fund if you know
if you want to figure out something that
vaynermedia is doing right you want to
come to New York and see it like if you
hear me say something about like
Facebook video or influencer Bartley
anyway it could be a help that I'm
interested you know my main my main
thing with like the young up-and-coming
guy from Atlanta and [ __ ] like that for
the music standpoint since the context
is I'm just trying to hack culture 24/7
365
it's just hacking culture if you can you
know I mean MC Compton paid attention to
more people than the game when he's at
that point of the career at once more
should come to you just supply and
demand so I just want to try to evaluate
people on the come-up bring them more
value know that 80% of them aren't going
to get through but the 20% of to is a
net positive and I'm still not going to
ask them for anything but it's nice to
have that's basically my thesis it's a
great piece
it's the tried and true are you doing
this for 40 years I'm not going to ever
be number one on Madden but I'm going to
buy the New York Jets and win a [ __ ]
Super Bowl yeah I think it does realize
young you don't belong at all it wasn't
right does it look like the waiters are
going to get to Vegas yeah looks like a
chick done that's not done not done
that's okay
you know it's crazy then what the [ __ ]
are they gonna do about the same color
scheme I'm I hang your mind state I
don't know about like starfish it robbed
me personally make [ __ ] charges
change themselves by the way yes
tomorrow
change your colors what's going on
what's going on what's going on with
your social
I watch you watch i watch you watch pork
okay what's her number
helps helps tell these characters not
the either tell them how really like a
real winner oh I remember something
publicly I got an organ sound cool
before I mean the work world one I gotta
go to stack oh I remember you ready for
this I love it no no no actually you
know what the version of that is I left
so early freshman year so early when I
came to campus sophomore year that's
what you're referring to I got out of
car I saw them sitting on the soup
drinking [ __ ] Spain eyes they looked
at me like I was a ghost like figure
about because there's no texting we need
to keep in touch Afiya
four months later wait there was a sweet
call 301 definitely all friends five
rooms the two outside rooms at for man
to live then re inside at two apiece and
I was only one was actually games dorm
betting is part of our crest where we
come in there
one point Gary set up a bar can't bring
us all the alcohol therefore as you like
functioning parks look at Denton plug
them in drunk asking gap get a DAP hat
you sit there injury
oh he was norm you know I carried me for
none oh my god Jack gain and I would
love to do I was putty from terracing or
the name Tom they would clean water pipe
it down remember to tiny funneled an
entire 750 of Jack Daniels and passed
out eight seconds later funnel jacking
Oh guys I'm telling if I was doing go
easy back then we would watch that like
and all the split shift tell them that
like the Spice Girl dolls number that
should wait to go to go we get up early
in the morning go these words Russ Gary
charge brought behind back you know I
didn't try I had him on payroll it was
rising never thought will and whatever
was I would pay guy 20 bucks a week
he would open up the toys and the
expensive ones he'd keep in the back I'd
come through and I get them all people
think this is new [ __ ] this is old
school stuff mmm-hmm I forgot that was
the main leaf eBay account
holy [ __ ] Madden you dominated madam
except for soakers run on me Halsey
those Jets that was you know what if you
see Mikey know when I talk about playing
that in my butt I was with Don Maynard
hall-of-famer that was the only time I
was good when the 69 Jets were
introduced I was too prideful and was
like I can let these guys please I'm a
rising she's a little cheap okay the
Indian kid and I beat him like 68 to
nothing how about the stress
uh-huh you look funny I really need to
like get some stories from you guys
because I forget things like I knew
really no I don't know a lot of things
but you look looks like oh sure I
remembered if I remember doing this I
remember when you guys all went to UConn
didn't take me Oh was it Mike my count
right no yeah oh I was - hi Alice
oh that was devastating to Arnold means
this is we wrote we wrote 21 now his
21st birthday
you actually we will preview that story
when I lost all my money in Vegas but
then I hit the trace walking out the
door you don't know the story that we
went for his 21st birthday this his 21st
birthday in Las Vegas in Las Vegas I get
there four hours early I come with like
three thousand dollars everybody else
comes new came with forty seven dollars
water baby for four days no no rate for
this Vegas for four days LA for three
days that mean cause a forty seven
dollars and go laughs because that's
what we have like we were it was get on
it anyway I get there and I [ __ ] saw
gambling and I'm losing like I've never
just easy and now I'm like scared
because I'm like [ __ ] I know I have to
like kind of help everybody else like
get through this week some feel a little
bit of responsibility so like I'm down
to its 1,500 like okay I'm gonna start
getting a hundred of time I got to get
back up ease and I've got like two
hundred dollars in four hours of use
$2,800 garage they haven't arrived then
they then they get there they like kind
of come in they're like I would be see
me and I'm white I'm already the most
white guy with the crew now real life
right they were like what so I'm like
depressed they're going to get settled
they're like pissed at me they thought I
was joking I'm like I lost my money so I
took the [ __ ] out of here dude I'm like
[ __ ] so I walk around with that no no
it's way better I don't think you'll
remember in a minute
I hear commotion I need to waste a
couple I need to clear my head I hear
commotion I look over some Asians are
going nuts not look he's got four Queens
in Caribbean poker one like a thousand
dollars and he gets up at least and
there's this family country family like
five characters like mom dad the kids
and they got real thick like Nebraska
accents and I'm like can I sit down
because like ten dollars a hand like
sure they're like super fun uh-huh third
hand third hand and the way I play
caribbean pokers I keep four cards down
I keep one down yeah I don't look at it
I put the four and I'm like three five
six seven all hearts and now like I'm
you know who I am Alex showing around
like do my thing but guys if I have a
full report so there's no thought I'm
thinking I got a straight for her for
part thirty five thousand four thousand
is the whole pot for a Royal Flush so I
got ten percent
$4,400 one hand I have to fill up the
taxing I sent the check home for two
thousand other mothers oh wow you walked
out we're walking out the casino and you
put it on five yes yes you know that's
our rules on five bang 3,500 no one
remember about that trip more than
anything the number one thing I remember
not Glenn jumping over the escalator
trying to get girls going the other way
not that not all that Bone Thugs and
Tupac song just came out and we listened
to it on the drive from Vegas to LA
that's the number one thing I remember
Oh before I don't got to hear about
Coach K no internet so we just would go
to the mall I'm like you know we'd be
sitting there and if it got boring
enough I'd be like hey let's go to the
mall and I'll buy a video game
everything okay literally that's what I
was getting rhesus legged Ruby Dee
playing for [ __ ] pimp sling or some
[ __ ] that nobody needs buzzer you
classics Diddy we go the ball and it
would be like so fun because that's how
we found out about PlayStation no
internet no internet but we get back
sophomore year we know we go let's go do
what we did last year and first
if I would come back with Bank and I was
like let's go to the mall yeah well if I
cash for everything
Sasha Vader's admit it so anyway [ __ ]
we went to the mall to buy a new Genesis
game I will never forget this actually
because you know we were so into video
we were like she's a walking KB toy
store it had a big display KB KB toys
and we were like what the [ __ ] is that
and I'll never forget it we're like we
do so expensive to like so much money
we're like and they were like do you
want to see a demo a battle arena
toshinden or whatever right the battle
arena Toshi I'm Daryl came with it right
it was a fighting game battle I'm almost
Shores battle arena Toshi under or so
like that yeah
and we're like okay and the [ __ ] was
like we didn't even understand were like
wait CD yeah cuz it was right we didn't
know so I brought it back we bought it I
wasn't gonna buy it like - I was it was
real mine was there ready for 40 bucks
like 230 you gotta get another game this
was the single reason he's like come on
in
yeah right - no not those two so I
bought it we get back and like in five
minutes they're just there in like ten
minutes
the word on campus everybody's in our
dorm like warts go [ __ ] is this it was
crazy
oh great
that's what we call it 11 is I love you
who watches have you got a minute yeah
those are some good story what a great
day to spend time with a number one
player on Manning and man there is a
number one player added now I to college
love it
that sounds if that's all your fans the
internet then we'll be on the Ashland
make changes about for the slowest day
and I'm slap you in the face
it'd be so great to say Oh
[Music]